I've spent six years hiding in the  darkness it's time to come back into the  light that bank yesterday that was  YouTube I burned your journey nobody saw  your face  when is the drive  out I should have never let you get me  involved in this  she's highly trained possibly  ex-military these guys connected the  single  really high up isn't it time we were  properly introduced  face to face you'd have remembered me  Phoebe  the only thing you have left a bargain  with is your life what do you think  Alexis is god damn cleaners  is this place to place enough for you  well she already has a diamond sir sir I  believe that she just declared war  you trust me now no not ever  again  office on the table you have five  seconds  last chance  a slobbery theta-d bazooka then text I'm  spotless ova the atilla's does the  antenna